okay first of all congrats on the
english thank you so how is engaged how
does it feel to be beyonce it feels
amazing we i
last week i started my dress experience
and it was amazing my mom cried it was
awesome okay what tea can you give us
about the dress because your style has
been off the charts
um
well there's four that i'm kind of
leaning towards
um so i haven't made my decision yet but
it's been really really exciting and
i've been fighting so hard not to like
show it to my fiance but i'm gonna be
strong
are you one of those people do you have
a pinterest board since you're a little
about your dress and you're like let's
just figure it out no
no i was never that girl um so i went in
with a really open mind which
actually i was a little bit nervous
about having an idea but now like the
half going in with an open mind was like
kind of made it a little bit more fun
yeah that's too serious
so recently you've worn such iconic
looks the barbie look i gotta say it was
like do you
i think the mtv valentino the barbie was
like iconic and amazing and i i also
felt very very confident in it which is
like i think fashion is
can be used as like armor and i really
felt really confident amazing what what
about it
i'm a sucker for like kind of an
oversized like moment like connected
with more skin tight and so probably the
oversized jacket yeah i mean it was
funny thank you so much um last question
what does the iphone seem to do i think
it i think that to me an is just someone
who's been able to live authentically
themselves truthfully
under crazy circumstances you know and
icon can be
fashion and i thought it could be
activism like an
who's just icon appreciated so someone
who's just commits to being themselves